military investigators are trying to
find out what caused an armored vehicle
to roll into water in Georgia
killing three soldiers during a training
exercise at Fort Stewart three other
soldiers were hurt in this accident
David Martin is at the Pentagon with
more on this story so David here's a
question what else do we know about
exactly what happened here
well we know this was a planned exercise
that took place at 3:00 a.m. Sunday
morning so while the rest of us were
sleeping troops from the 3rd Infantry
Division were out training in the dark
when a vehicle carrying six soldiers
rolled into the water three soldiers
were killed when their Bradley infantry
fighting vehicle like the one shown here
rolled over whether they drowned or died
from the force of the impact is not
known the other three soldiers in the
vehicle were hospitalized to have been
released and one has been transferred to
Memorial Medical Center and in Savannah
and is expected to make a recovery
maneuvering a 25-ton armored vehicle in
the dark comes with obvious risks even
if it was just training Congressman
buddy Carter's district includes Fort
Stewart it's a somber reminder of of
just how dangerous our soldiers are not
only in combat but the danger they're
put in in training as well in fact
accidents of all kinds are the single
biggest killer of American troops
according to a 2019 congressional report
between 2006 and 2008 teen almost twice
as many active duty service members were
killed in accidents than killed in
action so far rollover training
accidents have killed two other Army
soldiers this year in June 21 year-old
West Point cadet Christopher Morgan died
in a rollover which injured 19 other
cadets and two soldiers and in January
specialist Octavius lakes jr. was killed
when the Bradley he was riding in rolled
over during training at Fort Irwin
California every accident is
investigated in an effort to prevent
them from happening again but the danger
of military service can never be
entirely removed
either on the battlefield boy at home
base Tony well said David Martin for us
at the Pentagon David thank you very
much